[Applause]
benigno aquino iii came from a long line
of filipino politicians
he was the son of a much-loved president
as well as a national hero
his father benigno nina aquina jr a
well-known opponent of president
ferdinand marcus
was assassinated at manila airport in
1983.
his killing on the tarmac was described
as brazen
outrageous and shocking
his widow corazon aquino who had stayed
out of politics
took over his role she became the face
of a people power movement
that led to the end of the 21-year rule
by marcus regarded by many as a dictator
she eventually became the first female
president of the philippines
in 1986. his mother's passing in 2009
followed a huge outpouring of grief for
her
a symbol of democracy to many filipinos
she was a catalyst for him to run for
the highest post
in government he was sworn in as the
15th
president in 2010. my parents
sought nothing less and died for nothing
less than democracy
peace and prosperity i am blessed by
this legacy
i shall carry the torch forward at the
end of the day
for a man who had lived for so many
years in his parents shadow
aquino soon came into his own he focused
on fighting corruption
removing a sitting supreme court chief
justice
accused of corruption and jailing his
predecessor
former president gloria macapagal arroyo
for government irregularities
he pushed through a law on reproductive
rights
a feat many warned will be near
impossible
in a nation predominantly roman catholic
during his administration the economy
grew by an average
of more than 6 percent a year he
challenged china's territorial claims in
the south china sea
filing a case to the international
criminal court at the hague
and winning the major ruling declared
most of china's claim
invalid the victory was seen as
unprecedented
but aquino's presidency wasn't without
controversy
the philippines was battered by severe
natural disasters in 2013.
but he was mostly impatient with
criticism
especially with his government's low
response in dealing with typhoon haiyan
one of the strongest storms on record
two years later a botched operation to
capture a fugitive muslim fighter
killed more than 60 people including 44
police officers
and five civilians turning the armed
encounter
into aquino's biggest political crisis
he leaves behind a mixed legacy
but said all he ever wanted was to be
remembered
as someone who was given the honor to
serve the people
and he gave his best